[Applause]
why isn't he coming in i don't know
maybe he's not buying it hit me harder
[Music]
okay just go with me on this all right
i can't stay mad at you
huh
oh oh no
no is it working break it up
not my jail no no
stop it what are you doing
it's 2016 man this is on you less than
12 hours later the men escaped by
creating a disturbance in their cell
while they started kissing which i'm
fine with really i am kiss wherever you
want
except they were both men leslie knew
hey girl what's up pencil pushers
haverford good to see you man
is it hot in here i feel hot are you
guys hot how you guys doing i'm good you
guys got any snacks
carl is the head of all outdoor security
why was he transferred from his indoor
desk job you ask listen
hey leslie have you seen avatar i never
saw avatar i wanted to read the book
first but then i realized there's no
book version of avatar what'd you guys
do for saint patty's day i was wearing
this t-shirt that said kiss me i'm irish
but no one would kiss me
so
you're too important for me until one of
your own gets attacked
i just feel like there's more we can do
to keep the park safe oh you think you
know how to do my job
well you might not be so confident once
you've walked a mile in my size sevens
kind of small feet actually seven is a
worldwide average boom
i don't know leslie i'd rather be back
at the office i know this is painful for
you jerry but you have to be strong
you guys ready
oh boy yeah okay we're ready
i'm gonna show you guys all the problems
we've been facing let me show you we've
been doing everything we can i'm looking
forward to working together carl and
after that i'm gonna show you this log i
found
it's got like 50 worms on it
i call it worm log
yeah i've always been a bit of an
outdoorsman uh when i was a kid my
parents used to make me hang out in the
backyard a lot and just run around till
i got tired
but if there's any criminals out there
watching i never get tired
and ladies too
this is a mess we used to have three
carts actually the first one got pushed
into the creek by some kids
the second one raccoons got on too there
was urine everywhere and the third one
was recently stolen what's this one this
is the second one the raccoon piss one
all right so
we're gonna just head out
oh no
you know what i think we got too much
weight
oh
that's tom probably are you serious
tom can you get off please just run
alongside the cart okay
okay here we go
whoa
so let me tell you a little bit about
the park
uh up here on the left is uh one of our
most beautiful grass fields
uh it's primarily grass
but i'm gonna make a hard left here
stick with us tom
any of this looking familiar uh yeah it
happened right over there oh yeah
i'm not surprised
take a look at this path
with budget cuts we can't afford a
single safety light there's been 10
assaults already this year wow really
can't you station a park ranger out here
we have who do you think they're
assaulting
i'm sorry i didn't mean to yell
one way or another i'm gonna get money
so you can protect jerry and all the
other
helpless pathetic people in this town
you guys got to slow down
you have to take a rest for a minute no
tom sorry no can do sun's going down
it's real dangerous out here let's roll
carl okay going fast
i'm afraid you both have the mumps
mumps still a funny word
are we gonna die
so you both have the mumps sorry to say
it's very contagious
you may not want to be her detective oh
it's cool i keep up to date on all my
vaccinations i'm immune to stuff you've
never even heard of but not immune to
braggadocio
anyhow over the next several hours you
will more than likely develop fever
aching fatigue doesn't sound too bad
also tart foods will cause intense jaw
pain so you may want to avoid sour
candies what you may get painful greater
like swelling in your neck and often
extreme testicular discomfort
okay
due to the highly contagious nature of
the virus you will both be quarantined
to your houses for the next nine days
well nine days in isolation uh sir i'd
be happy to keep you company we could
watch the ten part nicholas nickleby
special on pbs yeah there's a lot of
long quiet stretches i do love long
quiet stretches but i don't want to be a
burden plus i'm getting used to being on
my own
or
we could be quarantined together you
know work the case
yes
that actually sounds kind of fun kind of
it's gonna be the best week ever i'm
sorry did you not hear me say extreme
testicular discomfort yes we heard you
dr bad news doctor
good morning everyone um i'm april
ludgate and i will be filling in for
leslie while she runs for office
so the new emergency protocol for the
parks department can be found
in your binders what exactly is the
chain of command vis-a-vis on-site
response hmm you know what why don't we
just say that whoever gets to the
emergency first will be in charge okay
so if there's an explosion say in
ramsett park and someone from sewage
gets there first
they'd be in charge
i had no idea how terrible leslie's job
is she referred to this meeting as a
non-stop thrill ride i'm not quite sure
but tom can answer that if
what are you doing it's bouncing some
business ideas off russell simmons on
twitter
why
all due respect miss lucky do you even
know what you're doing here i'll do
respect to mr hamster penis but no i
don't my last name is giles are you sure
because you look like a hamster penis i
knew this moment would come and i will
be the bigger man i'd be happy to help
great we need a doctor here immediately
we have to get your ex-boyfriend i will
not help you things did not end well
between frederick and me oh why not dish
sir dish gina no i can't believe i'm
saying this but we simply don't have
time to hear about the captain's sordid
romantic past what have you become a
hero in a time of crisis
you stay here and take care of sharon oh
what if she's still pregnant when i get
in there then you'll deal with it sir
we're going to get frederick right now
i'm sure he's over whatever little fight
you guys had
frederick happy thanksgiving
please don't slam the door again we have
a bit of a medical situation i wish i
could help but unfortunately i have a
bit of a wooden duck situation
excuse me what now still on about the
duck frederick years ago when we moved
in together an antique duck decoy of his
was misplaced it wasn't misplaced
you threw it in the trash
and with it our relationship oh please
we had other problems or have you
forgotten about
dave dave and i were co-workers and
nothing more nothing more
right
problem solved everybody's friends let's
go help sharon i would be happy to
assist you if you will just admit
raymond that you threw my decoy in the
garbage that will never happen because
it's not true thank you for nothing good
day
hi would you mind just standing there
with your glorious beard for one moment
i'll be right back
what the hell just tell him what he
wants to hear but it's a lie i don't
give a crap sir sharon needs a doctor so
get over yourself and tell him you threw
away his stupid duck and give him 20
bucks to buy a new one it cost 740
what that is an insane price for a duck
that's way too much all right now i'm
angry about the wrong thing look just
fix this for sharon
fredrik the duck was ugly and gross and
i threw it in the garbage wow well i
know what i'm thankful for this
thanksgiving the truth
hey it's me please open the door
come on let's talk i'm sorry
can i help you oh no you're not sophia
jake over here man oh
i am so sorry sir you were a wrong door
you were wrong door
hello hey you're bianca right uh-huh i'm
jake i'm a friend of freddy's from work
i'm looking for him well which jake are
you are you jakey ladyhands are you
jakey the jew well it feels weird saying
this but i hope jakey the jew
um
jake peralta
freddie actually said i should come by
here if i was ever in trouble oh okay
well freddie was here but he left but
come on come on in we've got the address
somewhere hold on
so did he say where he was heading or
heard about you peralta i know you were
the rat get him up get your hands up
[Music]
lady hands
you